have you ever wondered if you could just
upload an FAQ document and a chat board
would magically be created to answer
those questions or keep watching to find
out more
welcome to deconstructing chat BOTS I'm
Priyanka Vergara and in this episode we
will explore dialogue flows knowledge
connector feature at the time of this
recording knowledge connector is a beta
feature within dialogue flow knowledge
connector complements that defined
intents by parsing documents such as FA
cues or articles to find questions and
responses questions are added as
training phrases and answers are added
as responses to configure them you
define one or more knowledge bases which
are collections of documents at the time
of this recording CSV and HTML files are
supported for ingestion let's jump into
our dialogue flow console and see how to
set it up use an existing agent or
create a new one if you do not know how
to create an agent refer to the third
episode of the series where we are
building an appointment scheduler
because this is a beta feature we start
by going to the gear icon in enabling
the beta options now we're ready to
create our knowledge connector select
the knowledge beta from the Left pane
and click create knowledge base give it
a name and save now we need a knowledge
document that we can use to auto
generate the chat pod I have opened this
compute engine FAQ here as a sample
let's use this one let's go back to our
dialogue flow agent and create our first
knowledge connector I'm calling it
compute engine FAQ select a knowledge
type it is FAQ in this case select a
mime type in this case it is HTML file
and we add a URL to this document
once you have felt click create and just
like that the knowledge connector has
created the FAQ chat bot let's click on
our compute engine FAQ we see that the
Asians are parsed into requests and
responses neatly click on add response
to enable the automated responses that's
all just save before you test make sure
you have enabled the chat pod click on
the checkbox beside the name of the FAQ
and click enable now we are ready to
test in the simulator on the right query
your dialogue flow agent with what is
pricing for computer engine and you will
see a response from the bot try out more
examples like how do I get support you
will notice that I did not type the
exact same question from the FAQ and it
still gets mapped to the correct intent
that's the beauty of knowledge connector
today we learned how to create an FAQ
chat bot from HTML or CSV file in less
than two minutes try this awesome beta
feature and create some chat pods to
answer those FAQ questions automatically
once you do don't forget to share the
experience with us in comments I hope to
see you in the next episode of
deconstructing chat pods if you liked
this video and would like to see more
such content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]